hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
almost six years after we first heard
about cyberpunk 2077 it's now back in
the public eye and ready to take the
gaming world by storm but what the heck
is cyberpunk 2077 and why is everyone so
hyped for a game we haven't seen any
gameplay off well behind closed doors we
have indeed seen some gameplay
so here's 13 reasons cyberpunk 2077 is
worth the hype and I'll throw in a
little law - to get your head in the
right place so if you're ready let's do
list
CD Projekt RED are a studio to be
cherished with the sublime witcher
series the pinnacle of their craft The
Witcher 3 in particular commands
universal acclaim from reviewers with a
breathtaking open-world which showcases
the brilliance of CD Projekt both in
terms of technical prowess and narrative
might the world felt natural the quest
lines organic many characters held a
moral gray outlook which made
decision-making not as simple as good or
bad or right or wrong so what happens
when a studio with such talent for
storytelling and dedication to
perfection is given a new genre to work
with well you get cyberpunk 2077
what the heck does cyberpunk actually
mean the term is part of the sci-fi
genre which focuses on a future setting
where high levels of Technology ruled
the world but poverty and criminal
behavior is also on the rise too by no
means is this a new concept countless
films use a cyberpunk framework
these include Robocop ghost in a shell
cyborg even the matrix has cyberpunk
undertones but the one which you should
go and watch to get a real feel for
cyberpunk 2077 is Blade Runner
I need your deck this is a bad the worst
year I need the old blade runner' from
the footage we've seen from behind
closed doors it's quickly apparent that
cyberpunk 2077 is a mature themed game
I've seen naked ladies so much blood and
gore to give your grandma nightmares and
it's also possible to have one-night
stands with NPCs so maybe this isn't the
perfect gift for your ten-year-old the
devs have said that the world is noir
themed
just like Blade Runner where it's a
pretty depressing place to live
this is juxtaposed against the roaring
sunshine and bright neon lights
cyberpunk 2077 will almost certainly be
given an 18 or adult rating if that one
mission is the benchmark Knight city
will be our new home which sits in
between San Francisco and Santa Barbara
in the game this land was purchased by
Richard night in the hopes of creating a
safe city free of crime and oppression
as you can tell it didn't go according
to plan here in night city surviving the
day is an achievement in itself the
world is cutthroat and deadly when
Richard Knight built the city he left
out criminal corporations after four
years they became a little annoyed and
killed him taking over the projects
before eventually being pushed down by
the mega corporations we will fill the
boots of V a cyber enhance Street
warrior who you build from scratch will
your V be male or female maybe a few
tattoos to look edgy or what about a new
haircut complete with LED lighting CD
Projekt RED wants this character to
represent you so unlike The Witcher
where we're stuck with Geralt in
cyberpunk 2077 we have full agency over
our character even the backstory is
customizable to give your character
the upbringing they deserved and just in
case you're wondering all voice lines
have been recorded in both a masculine
gruff voice and the more delicate
feminine manner your character will have
many stats to improve and upgrade
including the typical RPG traditions
strength intelligence Constitution
reflexes and is another one called cool
I received conflicting reports on how
cool operates in the game some people
state it's about your characters ability
to keep calm under pressure whereas
other outlets suggests that cool works
in conjunction with the street cred
mechanic when hopping around the city
the higher the street credibility the
more options unlock whether that's the
prices at your local black market or
dialogue options which were previously
hidden from view oh and the freakin
awesome LED neon jacket v's wearing here
this will give you an instant boost to
your street cred come on that's a darn
cool jacket and you just know there is
going to be a collector's edition with
that jacket a general class system will
be at work in cyberpunk 2077 thanks to
cyber wear which allows for biotech
upgrades of V think of it like Deus Ex
and the neuro mods and enhancements the
three classes we can obtain are
netrunner for hacking abilities techie
which allows for renegade off-market
tech to be used and developed and
finally the solo class which is
essentially a trained killer like a
soldier or assassin the glasses are not
cut and dry though they can be combined
so if you'd like to use the Mantis
blades as seen in the original trailer
they'll be here but maybe you'll also
upgrade your netrunner abilities and
tack a few enemy augments at first
glance the freedom to play your way is
phenomenal probably the biggest
information to take from the initial
reveal of cyberpunk 2077 is the
viewpoint will be playing in
first-person perspective the devs have
made a very strict statement and are
pushing that it's not a first-person
shooter with RPG elements it's a
role-playing game first and foremost set
in first-person with some shooting
elements does that mean the gunplay is
as solid as Borderlands or destiny or
will it be a little more clunky like
fallout 4 from the one level we've seen
you've got nothing to worry about the
gunplay is solid as a rock
going back to classes for a moment did
you ever play cyberpunk 2013 of 2020
they were tabletop RPGs you know the
kind where you have so many dice it's
like a Christie
No well in cyberpunk 2020 there were 10
character roles we've already talked
about three of them solo techy netrunner
the others although not playable will
make up the lore elements around
cyberpunk 2077 within gangs and
communities the rocker boys use music
and the desire to oppose the corporate
juggernauts as a shared mentality the
nomads are road warriors that loosely
resemble a gypsy community the fixers
dealing information and knowledge add to
this the police force the corporate
regimes and the media outlets that deal
in propaganda and we've got a deep
gaming world to investigate so what
about combat inside the punk
although the RPG elements take center
stage the game is filled with
opportunities to go on the rampage the
standard cover shooting is here if
that's your bag but why not upgrade your
augments to allow for matrix style
slow-motion effects are kung fu movie
knee slides and double jumps these moves
are best suited to a solo build but if
you prefer the netrunner abilities then
you'll be able to hack into the enemy if
you can find a way to get close enough
to jack in the net runner has so many
unique skills to play with and the demo
show definitely focused on that
character build some of the coolest
things talks about behind closed doors
were about the tech on offer in the open
world there's a scanner that allows you
to see behind enemy cover there's a
weapon which will shoot straight through
that cover there's even a weapon type
which allows for bullets to deliberately
bounce from wall to wall and ricochet
into unsuspecting enemies there's even a
high level rifle called the smart rifle
which will track enemy movement and we
haven't even spoke about melee options
putting all these action elements
together and we've got one hell of a
video game let's jump back into law in
the game world again remember five and a
half years ago when the first teaser
trailer dropped it looked as if the
police force were attempting to take
down an unhinged citizen this
mantis-like lady has cyber psychosis
which is such a widespread issue that
there is a dedicated police task force
focused on bringing cyber psychos down
in the world of cyberpunk 2020 the more
augments a human added to their body the
more their brain would detach from
humanity then suddenly they would snap
completely with an uncontrollable desire
to kill every man and woman
they set their eyes upon this really
puts into perspective the harsh nature
of night cities
due to the size of the world travel
options will be imperative the Metro
subway is a great way to quickly get to
generally the right area but there are
cars and motorbikes to ride upon to
violence will follow you around the city
and this is where the camera can break
from first-person when driving a
third-person camera is possible and in
the footage we saw v asked an NPC to
drive while she shot the crap out of the
cars following them another vehicle
we've seen in the trailer are these
ships or hovercrafts but a last CD
Projekt RED don't want to talk about
these just yet so how does the world
tied together in cyberpunk 2077 in
addition to the typical quest lines you
are able to acquire quest from countless
NPCs just like in The Witcher 3 your
skills as a mercenary unlock further
quests to divert from the core story
it's even possible to stumble across
Equestria by overhearing Intel or
joining a random gunfight across the
street it's all about organic
storytelling there's even talk of a
multiplayer component which could be
added post launch more info on that as
we find out but at the moment it's only
a concept so let's move on did you spot
any easter eggs in the cyberpunk reveal
trailer I absolutely adore Easter eggs
and video games there's a handful here
so let's quickly look at them during the
shot of the metro map at the start of
the trailer take note of the n6m a wood
or eight one six reference number this
is a nod to Blade Runner and Roy batty
serial number he was the leader of the
renegade Nexus 6 group played
brilliantly if I grow to get our there's
some graffiti on the wall outside the
motel which reads he is Johnny arguably
a nod to the shiny and this scene
here's Johnny but most likely this is a
reference to a character in cyberpunk
2020 who was a famous rocker boy singer
and guitarist during the reveal on the
Xbox stage mindless text filled the
screen as if the stage was been hacked
but these jumbled numbers and letters
were actually gain codes
allowing those who paid attention the
opportunity to download The Witcher and
the DLCs - oh there's another one at the
end of the trailer for a split second
was another text field image to read
this is a personally written message to
the cyberpunk community thanking them
for their patience promising no DRM on
the PC and most noticeably laughing at
the thought of microtransactions you've
just got a love CD Projekt RED to end
let's talk about a release date at
present there is no plans to reveal a
release here nevermind a month so let's
start a competition when do you think
cyberpunk 2077 will be releasing throw
down your year and month guesses the
winner will be pinned in all its glory
my guess is September 2020 so they have
it cyberpunk 2077 looks like The Witcher
and Deus Ex smash together for me
that sounds bility awesome what do you
reckon is it worth the hype I'd love to
know your thoughts I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade as always it's been
a pleasure
I'll see you next
[Music]